we all have times in our lives where we
feel
broken
i just want my family to heal that's
what angelina says about her ongoing
custody battle with brad which she
describes as quote horrific angelina
also claimed she feared for the safety
of her children during their marriage
brad was cleared of any wrongdoing in
2016 after investigation of possible
child abuse in the new interview jolie
also tells the guardian she was hurt
that brad worked with disgraced producer
harvey weinstein even after she claimed
to him that weinstein tried to sexually
assault her in 1998.
brad however did confront weinstein in
1995 when he was dating gwyneth paltrow
he said if you ever make her feel
uncomfortable again
i'll kill you or something like that at
that moment you know i was a boy from
the ozarks on the playground i mean that
was that's how we confronted with things
pitt is currently producing a film based
on the new york times reporting of
weinstein's case
as for their nasty custody battle right
now brad is asking the california
supreme court to review a recent private
judge ruling that shot down his 50-50
child custody win
and speaking of their kids this weekend
angie shared pics of 15 year old shiloh
and 16 year old sahara with their
favorite books
that same day jolie's eternals co-star
salma hayek posted this video of angie
pushing her face into her birthday cake
as she celebrated her 55th birthday yep
it's all in good fun though salma
explained the cake smashing is a mexican
tradition
[Music]
you